now
[Music]
ask Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 230 of the askgaryvee
show
I'm ready Doug yeah what's up Gary
my name is Seth Silver's I live in
Denver huge Broncos fan which means we
have one thing in common we hate the
Patriots and I hate Bill Belichick so in
1999 when Bill Belichick was the head
coach of New York Jets for a very brief
time he famously said for various
reasons I'm choosing to resign there's a
head coach of New York Jets where you
have you and that happen did you hate
him yet or were you sad and the real
question is how many Super Bowls do you
think the Jets would have won if
self-awareness is very important but
self discipline can be even as important
how do you continue to be
self-disciplined
each day especially how did you stay
self disciplined in the early stages of
your entrepreneurship journey when the
results might not be there Chiefs 20
Jets 17 thanks
there's just no options Aleks like I
stayed self discipline because I wanted
to win people talk about wanting to win
but they don't actually want to win and
they're not willing to sacrifice to win
and so I did it cuz just know there was
a number of moment in my time whether
it's hardwiring or understanding of the
situation there was never a situation
where I thought that not being
disciplined or wavering or wasn't my
best interest and so I think when you're
fundamentally patient as I am it makes
everything quite easy everybody's just
antsy antsy for [ __ ] to happen so soon
so
hi Gary my name's Danny Knowlton d-roc
or whoever's editing this please hook me
up with my twitter handle I appreciate
that
my question to you Gary is I've just
been headhunted for a position at
Facebook but I'm currently running a
small but growing digital marketing
agency in the UK called KPS digital
marketing do I stop what I'm doing with
my agency and get someone else to manage
it and then go and work at Facebook to
get the experience or do I ignore the
position at Facebook and carry on
hustling and doing what I'm doing with
my growth that's a personal career
answer that's a personal question like I
can't answer that for you you need to
know who you are and what you're about
my intuition is anybody that even
questions to leave their own business to
go work at a company should go work at
that company yo yo what's up Gary Cory
Gregory here just pulled up to the gym
what your ass stuff for EM that's what
you get when you add right here
Cory G fitness on snapchat so here's my
question I'm a serial Fitness
entrepreneur I've been in business since
I was 20 years old so it's going on 18
years now and I love it
I'm known for on snapchat showing that
daily accountability that wake your ass
up and in it's nonstop I'm also known
for content in my space but I've never
had like a personal video guy that just
followed me around like d-roc tell me
the difference it means to your business
to have a guy like that I think I
already know that the answer but I'm
thinking about taking that next step and
truly having somebody capture what it's
taken me to do what I've done in my
career and I'll end with this we will be
friends so I'll see you soon Cory I
think it comes down to if you've got
something interesting to say or if the
contents interesting it has an impact
because the storytelling is good you
know as great as d-roc is a
cinematography or editing or Tyler
donker Stefan or [ __ ] Steven
Spielberg if the subject matter isn't
good it won't have upside even us and I
think nobody's living
a more fast-paced serendipitous for
creative content opportunity than I am
but look you know it's a repetitive
grind you know it's a challenge for
these guys to edit and make a creative
storytelling we're starting to interview
people within the organization we have
to mix it up because the fact of the
matter is a lot of our lives take on a
similar Acadian sand so doing something
daily you know people like Casey and
other people that do it extremely well
they make you know they look for the
story they create the story I'm not
doing that
I'm documenting over creating and so I
want to show that grime but there's only
so many times you can yell at us at 4
a.m. and saying let's go you know and so
I think I think the impact on your
business and your career and your brand
will be that if you've got chops if
you're actually interesting enough if
there's things going on especially if
they're not fabricated or created for
that scenario and they're authentic more
people will be interested in what you've
got you create a wider net you get an
opportunity then to speak to them I mean
some of the blog blogging we're doing
allows more people to get into my
ecosystem and allows me to drill home
the 4 or 5 things that I feel passionate
about telling the world because I want
them to win I think if you know if
you're there to sell products or
supplements or magazine covers if I was
here for selling you know being a media
or selling wine or my book I think they
would have less upside so I also think
not only is the storytelling matter but
what is the what is the thing you are
trying to accomplish really matters in
the scenario vlogging I think Casey for
example and I have a lot of love for him
but generally just as a filmmaker and
wants to tell stories and it's why does
well so we made a lot of people that
vlog that aren't going to do well
because they suck
what's up Gary the coach Kozak here and
I just like to get your thoughts on
friendships I'm a fellow hustler grinder
out here in the shed 24/7 working like
this want to know at this point in time
in your life and your career to even
make time I want to share just have
those couple of friends that are always
you know nagging me throughout the day
asking me if I've seen this TV show or
that TV show I mean at what point you're
just being rude or do you have to just
tell these guys to hey I don't have time
for friends today look I love my friends
and I actually wish I spent more time
with my friends I mean the fact matter
is this during the day outside of Jets
friends during jet season I don't
communicate with anybody about anything
until the day's wrapped up and I'll
catch up you know I think way too many
people are trying to be cool what's the
name Jonathan Joshua I think too many
people are trying to be cool and mean
like you ain't got time for [ __ ]
house of cards like following the life
you know I don't think there's any ever
time to like rag on your friends I think
in my mind I rag on my friends because
but but to actually like I want to be
polite I want to give them love like I
think it's super important to be
empathetic to a million different
lifestyles than if anything I'm trying
to work hard as in fact I think a email
Tyler the other day like I just think
I'm seeing a bunch of my high school
friends in the city next Thursday or
Lister's or you know so I you know I
don't know I mean like they're your
friends for a reason right I think a lot
of people are struggling with the
definition between friends and
acquaintances
I think acquaintances that want you to
watch Game of Thrones and play [ __ ]
Madden I think if you really want
something bad or probably an interesting
thing to cut out or navigate around I
think friends you need to be there for
all the time and try to fight for those
relationships because that brings as
much value as building the biggest
business in the world
I think you know who strategy was a good
store with Belichick and the Chiefs at
like like did you guys think you were
gonna get like some good rat like we're
kind of Zack Smith I'm currently a
physical therapy student at the
University of New Mexico I am a huge fan
of your work and I'm so grateful for all
of the value that you bring all of us
and I appreciate you taking my question
as a future business owner I'll be
deploying a lot of your strategies to
advertise for my business my question
for you is which platform do you spend
most of your time on these days thanks
for answering
what's platform um I mean I think um
what's his name Zack first of all thanks
for the love
Zack I think the platform it's running
the gamut Instagram snapchat I still
continue to use Twitter I don't think
people understand like Twitter is still
the one place to have unbelievable
engagement and I truly believe so much
of my world is predicate engagement that
being said snapchats the place where
when I actually reply I just get so many
guns you know people go crazy you know
it's funny I love the way the ui/ux of
Twitter I can just get to so many more
people than all like the pressing
waiting the speed in which snapchat
engagement works doesn't allow me to do
as many as I'd like to
which is disappointing because the
upside of engaging on somebody snapchat
is holy [ __ ] whereas on Twitter it's
like thanks and that's a very big
different reaction I would take Twitter
Facebook snapchat Instagram that's where
I'm spending most of my time you know I
think I think this is a great
opportunity for me to answer a question
so many you've been asking which is
Instagram stories or snapchat stories
the answer is both all for those
platforms have enormous attention for me
and so I continue to focus on them and
and and engage in create and pound and
and and work with my team on our
strategies and so all four platforms are
extremely important to me as the pillar
and foundations and so there's not one
that is you know dominating I'm sure if
I look at my time of usage one is
greater than the
they're depending on how I use them but
in my mind from a strategy standpoint
all four extremely important and I think
for most of you all four of those and
including the LinkedIn
LinkedIn's of the world and periscope
and in the Facebook lives scenario I
mean there's just so much opportunity
for us to storytelling grind I just
think people need to put in the work and
I think they all bring different value
for different reasons and that's why I
use them Facebook has ungodly reach
potential nothing is remotely close to
Facebook's capability to replicate a
television like platform Instagram is
just depth of attention
especially with stories now it's done
extremely well just a month ago or eight
weeks ago I was talking about being
concerned about Instagram plays I think
the stories feature was a monstrous move
snapchat for the you know the sixteen to
twenty five to twenty eight-year-old
demo is that game and super important
for so many of us out there and Twitter
is the only place where you can listen
at scale and engage and create that
conversation I mean I don't know where
everybody was last night during the
debate but I have a funny feeling it
wasn't Instagram Facebook and snapchat
and so that is the wallet water-cooler
of our society and there's a lot of
opportunity there maybe for not as much
talking but it is the one place I would
listen over any other platform that
question today what are the social
networks that you are using most sorry
for the saltiness I'm surprised to
carried-over I was actually a fairly
good mood yesterday but looks like some
characters and my team decided to put me
in the salt so I went in this salt and
I'm gonna stay in the salt until I get
out of the salt keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
I wasn't even right
[Music]
and
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]